Donald Trump es el presidente con el discurso
más hostil hacia los hispanos de las últimas
décadas.
Tal vez de toda la historia de los Estados
Unidos.
Sus comentarios en contra de la inmigración,
los mexicanos, los salvadoreños o declaraciones,
sin ir más lejos declaraciones como éstas
explican porque una buena parte de los hispanos
no tragan al Presidente Trump.
[TEXT: 1.
“Están trayendo drogas, están trayendo
crimen, son violadores, y algunos, supongo
que son buenas personas.”
2.
“Los africanos-americanos y los hispanos
están viviendo en el infierno, porque es
muy peligroso, si caminas por la calle te
disparan”.]
Pero, amigos, no penséis que en VisualPolitik
pensamos que una persona no puedo cambiar
de opinión o de discurso.
Al fin y al cabo, rectificar es de sabios…
¿Y sabéis?
En cierto modo, aunque os pueda sorprender
Trump lo está haciendo.
Un momento, ¿Que no os lo creeis?
Pues… ¡Vaya que sí lo ha hecho!
Fijaos, fijaos cómo han cambiado las cosas:
[TEXT: “Amo a los inmigrantes, amo a los
inmigrantes.
Este país está basado en inmigrantes, nuestro
país está basado en inmigrantes.]
Vaya cambio, ¿No os parece?
Amigos, la pregunta es… ¿Qué demonios
ha pasado?
Pues… No, no es porque Trump haya hecho
una profunda reflexión espiritual, ni tampoco
porque de repente se se haya conmovido con
la situación de la comunidad hispana.
Y no, tampoco, ni siquiera es porque se le
haya pegado el último hit de Jennifer López.
Qué va, para nada.
¿Queréis saber qué se esconde detrás de
este cambio de juego?
Pues… atentos.
El voto hispano.
Amigos, quedaos con estas tres palabras porque
pueden ser clave en las próximas elecciones
de 2020 en los Estados Unidos.
Para que os hagáis una idea los hispanos
suponen ya el 18% de la población total de
Estados Unidos y este porcentaje no para de
crecer.
(Los hispanos no solo son ya la primera minoría
del país, sino que además son la minoría
que más crece.
Según todas las proyecciones y todos los
modelos demográficos, para el año 2060 el
porcentaje de población hispana superará
el 26% de la población de los Estados Unidos.
Dicho de otra forma, algo más de 1 de cada
4 estadounidenses serán hispanos.
Y evidentemente eso es algo que poco a poco
les va a ir dando una influencia electoral
cada vez mayor.
Hacer políticas o tener discursos en contra
de los hispanos no parece la mejor forma de
cosechar éxitos políticos)
De cajón, ¿No os parece?
Sin embargo, amigos esperad un momento porque
hoy por hoy su peso electoral, el peso electoral
de la comunidad hispana es mucho, muchísimo
más bajo de lo que podría ser.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque si hay algo que caracteriza en
Estados Unidos al voto hispano es que resulta
muy complicado de movilizar.
Los hispanos se caracterizan por su baja participación
electoral en las elecciones de los Estados
Unidos.
[Mal, muy mal, fatal.]
Pero… ¿Por qué se produce este fenómeno?
¿Cómo es exactamente el electorado hispano?
¿Qué les preocupa?
¿Cómo se reparte el voto hispano a lo largo
y ando del país?
Parecen muchas preguntas, pero os prometo
que vamos a responder a todas y cada una de
ellas.
¿Queréis conocer cuál es la radiografía
del voto hispano en los Estados Unidos?
Atentos.
(HISPANOS, LA MINORÍA MAYORITARIA)
Si echamos un vistazo a los principales grupos
étnicos de Estados Unidos nos vamos a dar
cuenta de que la población hispana tiene
algunas características peculiares.
Y como ya hemos dicho no hablamos de una comunidad
precisamente pequeña.
Casi 60 millones de hispanos vivían en este
país al terminar el año 2018.
Esto hace que Estados Unidos sea ya el segundo
país hispano en términos de población.
Aunque parezca difícil de creer Estados Unidos
tiene más población hispana que países
como Colombia, Argentina o España.
(La comunidad hispana en los Estados Unidos
crece en términos demográficos a un ritmo
del 2% anual.
Y durante las últimas décadas sus niveles
de vida han mejorado mucho.
Hoy el desempleo hispano se encuentra próximo
a su mínimo histórico, por debajo del 5%;
la tasa de abandono escolar ha bajado del
29,4% en 1992 al 9,2% en 2015.
Y la tasa de hispanos inscritos en la Universidad
ha subido del 25 al 47% en tan solo 10 años,
entre el 2005 y el 2015)
Bien, los datos son buenos, francamente buenos...
Y eso es algo que les augura mucha mayor influencia
económica, política y social.
Para que os hagáis una idea tan sólo desde
el año 2000 el poder de compra de los hispanos
en Estados Unidos ha aumentado un 181% y ya
se eleva a 1,4 billones de dólares.
Y… ¿Sabéis qué significa esto?
Qué los Estados Unidos son la mayor potencia
económica hispana del mundo.
La economía hispana en Estados Unidos es
más grande que toda la economía española
o la economía mexicana.
El poder hispano cada vez más estará en
Estados Unidos.
Sin embargo, no todo es de color de rosas
(En términos de renta y pobreza la población
hispana aún está muy por detrás de la población
blanca y de minorías como la asiática.
A pesar de la buena evolución más del 19%
de los hispanos, 1 de cada 5, se encuentran
aún por debajo del umbral de la pobreza según
los estándares de Estados Unidos y sus ingresos
medios per cápita no llegan a los 19.000
dólares anuales, la mitad que el de los blancos.)
Pero… No nos desviemos, REGRESEMOS a la
política… qué al fin y al cabo es de lo
que va este vídeo.
La población hispana es una población muy
joven.
Su media de edad es 10 años inferior a la
media nacional y 15 años más pequeña que
la de los blancos.
Esto es algo que evidentemente condiciona
las preferencia y el grado de participación
política de esta comunidad.
Y en parte es también lo que explica que
mientras los hispanos suponen ya el 18% de
la población del país, en términos de votantes
potenciales apenas suponen el 11% [Y encima
votan menos]
Por todo esto es por lo que todavía su influencia
política es relativamente pequeña.
Pero esto es algo que está cambiando.
(LA DISFUNCIÓN DEL VOTO HISPANO)
Queridos amigos, a simple vista, si echamos
un vistazo al mapa, la distribución de la
población hispana podría indicar que son
una comunidad determinante para las elecciones.
¿Por qué?
(Cómo todos sabéis, en las elecciones norteamericanas
el candidato presidencial que obtiene la mayoría
en un estado se hace con todos los delegados
de ese estado.
Es así en prácticamente todos los casos..
Es un todo o nada, cero o uno.
Por eso la victoria presidencial depende de
sumar más delegados que el contrincante,
no más votos.
Y eso hace que los Estados que más delegados
repartes sean el caramelito que se rifan los
candidatos presidenciales)
Pues amigos, en ese caramelito resulta que
los hispanos tienen una presencia muy alta.
La población hispana se concentra en términos
absolutos principalmente en California, Texas,
Nueva York, Florida e Illinois. 5 de los 6
estados que más delegados reparten en las
elecciones:
171 de 538 totales.
¿Entendéis por qué a simple vista deberían
ser cruciales en las elecciones?
Pues....
Lo cierto es que lo son… y no lo son.
Veríamos, muchos analistas aseguran que el
voto hispano puede decidir presidentes, pero
la verdad es que nosotros hoy por hoy no lo
tenemos tan claro.
Al menos no en las elecciones de 2020.
¿El problema?
Ya os lo hemos dicho: Los hispanos apenas
van a votar.
(De entre todos los grupos étnicos, los hispanos
son el menos movilizado electoralmente.
Por ejemplo, en las últimas elecciones presidenciales
en 2016, tan solo se registraron para votar
poco más del 57% con derecho a voto.
Poco, pero es todavía peor si os decimos
que al final terminaron votando tan solo el
47,6%.
Casi 20 puntos menos que participación política
de los blancos)
Pero..
¿Por qué diantres los hispanos pasan tanto
de las elecciones?
Pues….
Bien, factors hay muchos, pero el más importante
es que como os hemos dicho es una población
mayoritariamente joven.
Y que quereis que os diga, fuera de la Comunidad
de VisualPolitik, parece que los jóvenes
suelen pasar más de la política.
Pero ese no es el único motivo.
El menor nivel medio de estudios y de ingresos
también son cosas que alimentan la apatía
política.
Pero claro, llegados a este punto seguro que
alguno de vosotros estaís pensa… Va, ya,
que sí, que como siempre.
Pues amigos sí… y no.
Os lo estamos venga a decir: Poco a poco esta
divergencia respecto a la población blanca
no hispana se está recortando.
Los hispanos cada vez estudian más, cada
vez ganas más dinero y cada vez votan más.
Fijaos por ejemplo en lo que ocurrió en las
elecciones más recientes, en las de mitad
de mandato.
(La participación de los latinos aumentó
un 178% en las elecciones de mitad de mandato
de 2018, según los Demócratas.
- The Guardian)
Y claro… se lo que estás pensado… Entonces,
si el problema de movilización de la comunidad
hispana se está solucionando… ¿Podrían
ser decisivos en 2020?
Bien… Veámoslo.
(¿PODRÍAN LOS HISPANOS DECIDIR LA ELECCIÓN
DE 2020?)
Amigos, una pregunta… ¿recordáis las palabras
de Trump que vimos al principio del vídeo?
No no, no me refiero a esas en las que insulta
a los hispanos, sino a las de después, a
esas en las que de repente incluso parece
que les ama.
Pues bien, ese cambio de opinión podría
tener bastante que ver con lo que os vamos
a contar a continuación.
(Los hispanos podrían marcar la diferencia
en 2020 (si van a votar).
- Univision)
Un dato importante: las elecciones de 2020
serán las primeras elecciones de la historia
de Estados Unidos en las que los hispanos
serán la minoría con más peso electoral,
superando ya a la población negra.
(Con 32 millones de votantes potenciales,
en 2020 los hispanos supondrán el 13% del
padrón electoral.
Serán 2 millones más que los votantes negros.
Y hoy por hoy entre los hispanos la dinámica
es clara: 2 de cada 3 suelen votar a candidatos
del Partido Demócrata.
Pero la explicación a esto no es que sean
demócratas o republicanos, sino el empeño
sistemático que ha tenido el Partido Republicano
por ponerles en contra durante los últimos
años.)
Sí, sí así es.
Frente a lo que se suele pensar el voto hispano
es extremadamente volátil, quizás el que
mas.
La mayoría no se identifica como votante
seguro de un partido sino que oscilan mucho
en función de los candidatos y las propuestas
políticas que pongan sobre la mesa.
Y eso en la campaña de Trump lo saben.
(Todos los estudios apuntan que la economía,
junto a la mejora de la educación y la seguridad
son los 3 temas que más le importan a los
votantes hispanos.
Y lo cierto es que la economía de Estados
Unidos ha funcionado bastante bien durante
los últimos años.
Por ejemplo, los ingresos de los hogares hispanos
son lo que más rápido están creciendo o
recordad también que el desempleo hispano
se encuentra en mínimos históricos.
De hecho, aunque sigue siendo escasa, apenas
un 30%, la popularidad de Trump entre los
hispanos ha repuntado ligeramente)
Por eso, aunque os pueda resultar sorprendente
en la campaña de Trump no se han resignado
ni por un segundo a no mejorar sus niveles
de apoyo entre la comunidad hispana.
La campaña “Vamos to Victory” es una
buena prueba de ello.
(Más hispanos piensan que la campaña de
Trump "toma en serio" a la comunidad, aunque
son minoría quienes dicen que votarán por
él.
- Univision)
Y la pregunta es, ¿Podría ser este el último
cartucho de Trump?
Un voto hispano desmovilizado de entrada le
beneficia, pero… ¿Y si se mobiliza?
¿No sería acaso más sensato reforzar su
posición en ese caladero nuevo de votos?
[O al menos no darles motivos para movilizarse
contra él.]
Y amigos, lo cierto es que todo apunta a que
en esta ocasión los hispanos votaran con
mucha más fuerza.
Parece que su participación batirá todos
los récords en unas presidenciales, tal y
como sucedió en las elecciones de mitad de
mandato.
(La participación electoral hispana en 2018
se incrementó drásticamente en seis estados,
según un análisis.)
¿Os suenan de algo algunos de estos Estados?
Exacto, ahí le has dado.
De esos cinco donde más se incrementó el
voto hispano, ni más ni menos que cuatro,
California, Florida, Nueva York y Texas, son
de los que más delegados reparten.
Dicho de otra forma, son los más importantes
en las elecciones presidenciales.
Así que visto lo visto, ¿logrará la comunidad
hispana ser decisiva en esta ocasión?
¿Logrará Trump mejorar su popularidad entre
los hispanos?
Desde luego a pesar de todo si la economía
va bien… no es descabellado que ocurra.
Sin embargo, la guerra comercial está teniendo
consecuencias duras para Estados Unidos y
la desaceleración económica es un hecho.
Sí 2020 se pone peor, puede incluso que sean
los hispanos los que echen a Trump de la casa
blanca.
Lo que tendría gracia…
En fin… ahora turno para ti:
¿Conseguirá Trump ser reelegido haciendo
que los hispanos olviden todo lo que ha dicho
y hecho o por contra estaremos a las puertas
de una gran venganza?
Dejadnos vuestras respuestas en los comentarios
y si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvideis darle a like.
Y por cierto un último mensaje.
Si ves VisualPolitik, eres hispano y vives
en los Estados Unidos, si puedes tienes que
ir a votar.
Vota lo que te dé la gana pero vota.
En fin, muchas gracias una vez más por estar
ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.